كان من المفترض أن تكون هذه إجازة عائلية على الشاطئ
بدلاً من ذلك ، فهذا دليل على أن شقيقتين
تقولان عن الحياة التي عاشوها تحت
الاضطهاد كل يوم كانت بمثابة
كابوس كانت هذه العطلة في سريلانكا في
سبتمبر الماضي أيضًا مسرحًا
لمحاولتهم الدرامية للهروب من
أسرتهم روان.  وريم ليست أسمائهم الحقيقية
شقيقتان من المملكة العربية السعودية تبلغان من العمر 18 و 20 عامًا لأمنهما ،
لقد طلبوا منا عدم إظهار وجوههم
جيدًا منذ أن كنا مراهقين عانينا
من العنف وأردنا
الهروب من هذا الذي كان يرتكب
العنف والأسرة في ظل
نظام ولاية الرجل في المملكة العربية السعودية ،
تتمتع النساء بحقوق قانونية أقل من الرجال الذين أُجبروا
على التستر وغير قادرين على السفر أو حتى
التقدم بطلب للحصول على جواز سفر دون إذن الزوج
والأب أو الأخوة منذ سنوات ،
تخلت هاتان الأخوات عن الإسلام سراً
جريمة يعاقب عليها بالإعدام  في المملكة
العربية السعودية وبدأوا في التخطيط
للهروب
في عطلة عائلية في سريلانكا
رأوا فرصتهم ولكن كان عليهم أولاً
الحصول على  لقد تسللت جوازات سفر والديهم
إلى غرفة والديك ، نعم
أثناء نومهم ،
لذلك أنا فقط للحصول على جواز السفر الخاص بك ، نعم
في منتصف الليل هربوا إلى
سيارة أجرة منتظرة
وخلعوا العبايات السوداء الطويلة التي أجبروا على ارتدائها
من  تبلغ من العمر 11 عامًا وأنت
تبتسم الآن في مطار كولومبو ، فقد اشتروا
تذاكر وحصلوا على بطاقات صعود
للخطوط الجوية السريلانكية إلى هونج كونج ثم
طيران كاثي باسيفيك إلى ملبورن
أستراليا حيث رتبوا بالفعل
تأشيرات سياحية عبر الإنترنت ولكن عندما
هبطوا في هونغ كونغ
المطار الدولي ، التقى بهم مدير محطة الخطوط
الجوية السريلانكية وممثل عن مجموعة Jardine
Aviation Services Group عند
البوابة وسألهم عن تصاريح الصعود إلى الطائرة ،
لقد أظهرت لك التخرج وكنا
نسأل عما يحدث لماذا تسير
بسرعة وقالوا إن الطائرة ربما تكون أنت.
لم يتمكنوا من اللحاق به أثناء سيرهم
عبر المطار تم اقتيادهم إلى مكتب
طيران الإمارات وتغيرت القصة
وقال الآن هناك  شخص من تلك
القنصلية السعودية
هل تشرح وأنت تعلم في ذلك الوقت
أننا اعتقدنا للتو أننا بنديكت السريلانكية
إيرلاينز بمعنى إيان وهذه الرواية التفصيلية
تدعي أن هذا الرجل
عبد الله حسين الشريف نائب
قنصل القنصلية السعودية في هونغ
كونغ جاء إلى  وطلب من
شركة الطيران تغيير مسار رحلة الشقيقة ،
أبلغ مسؤولو القنصلية السعودية
موظفي الخطوط الجوية السريلانكية
أن أم
الركاب كانت مريضة ، ولذلك
طُلب من الركاب العودة إلى الرياض على الفور ،
أخبرت الخطوط الجوية السريلانكية CNN
المسؤولين السعوديين بإلغاء تذاكر الشقيقة
إلى أستراليا  وطلبنا
تصاريح صعود جديدة لأخذهم إلى دبي ثم
المملكة العربية السعودية عندما نصرخ في وجهه
قائلين
إعادة جواز سفري ليس لديك الحق في
أخذه أيها البلوري ،
سنخبر المتنمرين أنه خائف ، ثم أخذنا
جواز سفرنا وركضنا حرفيًا
هذه ليست المرة الأولى
التي يحاول فيها مسؤولون حكوميون سعوديون منع
النساء من الفرار  نانوغرام في تايلاند
الشهر
الماضي ، تحصنت راحة فالكون هون البالغة من العمر 18 عامًا
في غرفة فندق وأخذت إلى
الإنترنت تتوسل للمساعدة في منع
الترحيل إلى المملكة العربية السعودية ،
وتم تصوير دينا علي شهوة لود من قبل
ركاب في مطار مانيلا في عام
2017 أجبرهم ذكر على ذلك.  أقاربها على
متن رحلة العودة إلى المملكة العربية السعودية
لم يسمع عنها نشطاء منذ عودتهم إلى
هونغ
كونغ ، واتهمت الأخوات نائب
القنصل السعودي عبد الله الشريف بالتدخل
في محاولتهما الصعود على متن رحلة لاحقة كانتاس
متجهة إلى أستراليا
مما دفع مسؤولًا أستراليًا
للإلغاء.  تأشيراتهم
رفضت وزارة الشؤون الداخلية الأسترالية إخبارنا بسبب إلغاء التأشيرات
قائلة إنها لا تعلق على
الحالات الفردية التي
تقطعت بها السبل بالأختين في المدينة
منذ ذلك الحين هل تعتقد أن هاتين
الأخوات في خطر هنا في لوس أنجلوس ، نعم أفعل
حقوق الإنسان  قدم المحامي مايكل فيدلر
شكوى جنائية نيابة
عن الأخوات الذين
زعمنا أنهم تعرضوا لمحاولة كيدنا  pping أنا
لا أذهب إلى المطار الدولي في
المنطقة المحظورة ، ونزعم أنهم
حصلوا على وثائقهم عن طريق المقعد
، ثم استخدموا وثائقهم بشكل غير قانوني
لإلغاء تصاريح الصعود إلى الطائرة ،
ويقول المهاجم إن فريقه قد فحص
لقطات كاميرا أمنية بالمطار تظهر هذا الرجل
القنصل العام السعودي في  هونغ كونغ عمر
إلبا نجايون الذي يظهر هنا في المطار في
أوقات أكثر سعادة ، يقول المحامي إن
الدبلوماسي تم تصويره وهو يحمل
جوازات سفر الأخوات وبطاقات صعود الطائرة في
المطار في السادس من سبتمبر ، وهو سؤال مهم
هنا لماذا يُزعم شخصياً أعلى مسؤول سعودي
في هونغ كونغ
تدخلت في
سفر امرأتين سعوديتين بالغتين ،
تواصلت CNN عدة مرات مع
وزارة الخارجية في ريو
والقنصلية هنا في هونغ كونغ ولم
تتلق أي رد على الإطلاق ، لكن شرطة هونغ كونغ
أخبرت شبكة CNN أنها تحقق رسميًا الآن في
ما حدث في
المطار في اليوم التالي.  في ذلك اليوم
، أنكر كل من الخطوط الجوية السريلانكية ومجموعة Jardine Aviation Services Group
ارتكاب أي مخالفات قائلين إنهما لم يفعلوا ذلك
الضغط على الأخوات لتغيير رحلاتهن
الجوية ، أما بالنسبة للأخوات اللواتي ما زلن
يعشن مختبئات في هونغ كونغ على أمل
الحصول على اللجوء السياسي ، فإن لديهن
رسالة تحد لعائلتهن في
الوطن ، أريد أن أكون امرأة ناجحة وأن أقدم
لهن هذه الرسالة.
نجاحي أنهم لا يستطيعون كسر لي إيفان
واتسون سي إن إن هونج كونج